cercottes près d'orléans dernière fois
que ce boulanger remonte son rideau
après neuf ans d'activité maxime vorey
jette l'épongé jours
ça vous fait quoi l'émotion et
l'inquiétude pour l'avenir
la boulangerie tout avait pourtant bien
commencé
un commerce bien placés dans ce village
de 1400 habitants 220000 euros de
chiffre d'affaires
il a suffi que deux chaîne de
boulangeries s'installe ta proximité
pour que tout bascule
à l'heure actuelle il a encore deux qui
vont s'ouvrir dans quelques mois donc
ça nous a fait baisser le chiffre et
puis avec toutes les charges qu'on a qui
arrivent à droite à gauche on peut plus
on peut maintenir le cap quoi un chiffre
d'affaires en baisse de 30% alors pour
limiter les frais de personnel maxime
bord et enchaîne les heures mais le
salaire ne suffit pas ces 500 euros pour
80 à 90 heures par semaine quatre-vingt
dix heures de travail par semaine ça
fait beaucoup
trois cent mille euros investis à perte
est impossible de trouver un repreneur
heureusement il possède un deuxième
commerce à quelques kilomètres dont on
est toujours en train de dire c'est la
mort d'un village qui a pas de vengeance
pas de comètes et là on ferme une
plongée frein mais les gens qu'on pas de
véhicule et vont faire comme quand on
commence à l'étranger on n'a pas
toujours aller dans les supermarchés a
pour aller chercher du pain à la sortie
de cercottes les voici ses concurrents
quel est donc le secret de leur réussite
aucun n'a accepté de nous ouvrir ses
portes en caméra cachée premier constat
ici il n'ya que le pain qui est fait sur
place et les viennoiseries sont faites
sur place et des batteries mais non
ses surgelés du surgelé donc moins de
main d'oeuvre et du volume
c'est ce qui permet de casser les prix
90 centimes la baguette ici à l'unité
même trick à la boulangerie du village
mais vendus par 10 le prix tombe à 60
centimes des prix bas un parking
tout ça au bon endroit aujourd'hui des
centres-villes n'est plus l'emplacement
idéal
thierry folliard vend des fonds de
commerce dans le loiret les bons
endroits
ils les repère tout de suite ici un
terrain vierge qui demandent qu'à être
utilisé donc voilà pour moi très bel
emplacement mais on est sûr à côté de la
tangentielle 25 mille véhicules jour 25
mille clients potentiels par jour le
matin achats de viennoiseries le soir
achat de pain et le midi cinq mille
personnes qui travaillent dans cette
zone d'activité qui est juste là ça veut
dire 5000 sandwich est possible pour
garder des boulangeries au coeur des
villages certaines communes doivent
mettre la main au portefeuille
clemmons 750 habitants en sologne
le maire nous emmène voir l'ancienne
boulangerie impossibles à vendre
pourquoi n'a pas trouvé un repreneur
alors elle s'il y avait des difficultés
qui était le stationnement et
l'accessibilité pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite
pascal et marche 1 point y accéder tout
à fait ça aurait nécessité des travaux
de mise aux normes
alors pour deux cent mille euros la
commune en a fait construire une neuve
toute équipe est mieux placé si vous ne
l'avez pas construit ça me rangerai
aujourd'hui dans le village ils auraient
pu les boulangers non je pense qu'il n'y
aura plus de danger
mais au-delà de ça je pense qu'il
n'aurait même plus de commerces du tout
puisque quand les gens on va acheter
leur pain quelque part forcément ils
font leurs courses accessoires à côté 90
mille euros investis pour acheter le
fonds de commerce un loyer de 600 euros
angélique et jérémy pasquet se sont
laissés tenter
dans les paires à dippach par le village
et puis c'est un petit coin de sologne
puis par rapport à la structure du
magasin qui est tout neuf qui est en
très bonne état pas d'employer plus de
150 heures de présence à yves eux il n'y
a qu'à ce prix là que l'affairé rentable